after the tokyo mangy gang disbanded on
the 8th of march 2006 the entire region
exploded into an era known as the
warring states period throughout this
period an unprecedented amount of
different gangs tried to take control
but none of these could ever truly get a
firm hold on the power eventually though
the power struggle stopped and three
extremely powerful individuals but he
stopped the conflict and each
subsequently claimed a part of tokyo as
his or her own territory one of these
three gangs that claimed a part of tokyo
came to be known as the strongest gang
that works in the shadows with the
figurehead of this organization being
the unrivaled boss of brahman kawaragi
senju so in today's video i'm going to
go over the unrivaled strength of
katawagi senchu and her possible
relation to one of the three unifiers of
japan with a possible relation that the
brahman gang and senju may be related to
some metaphysical concepts and hindu
philosophy which itself has a deeper set
meaning throughout this entire arc but
just before we get into this video if
you are new around here and want to keep
up to date with the latest tokyo
revenge's content and just like other
anime content in general then make sure
you hit that subscribe button and also
be sure to leave a like on the video as
it really helps out with the algorithm
and pushes my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but anyway enough of that
let's get into this video so as the
current reigning leader of brahman senju
is responsible for the status and
welfare of her gang and as i said
previously brahman and senju came into
power as an unknown point throughout the
two-year gap between march 2006 and
march 2008 by the roku heart of tandai
the rival gang of both brahman and kanto
wasn't formed until sometime throughout
2007. so i would assume that brahman
wasn't created until around at least a
similar point towards probably the end
of 2006 or maybe the start of like 2007
meaning that even though the entire
world itself and this story has
escalated in violence senju has managed
to hold down her entire gang a gang
which is considered to be the strongest
senju has command of an incredibly crazy
and stacked fighting force that has the
allegiance of the former first
generation black dragons captains one of
which is her older brother and the other
two are known as the strongest duo in
all of the stories so far wakasa and
benkei despite this mental and physical
age difference of at least 10 years
between senju and her other subordinates
she still somehow remains at the top of
the ranks i think this alone goes to
show just how mentally and physically
superior she is to others even though
there is this massive age gap and a
bunch of insanely strong fighters that
we know can lose it at any moment and
just start rampaging she can still pull
back the reins on them and control her
gang just how she likes her i think it's
even more evident with the fact that
senju recently had almost lost control
of all of her forces and was facing
utter defeat at the hands of tarano yet
single-handedly she made the decision to
show everyone her true strength and no
longer hold herself back and in an
extremely reminiscent way just like
mikey she flew through the air and
before anyone could even react tyranno
was lying at her feet almost exactly how
in an instant maki took down the giant
taiju yujili senju would fight from the
shadows having her brother orchestrate
decoys for her so that she can hit the
enemy with a bunch of sneak attacks but
that was only ever because she didn't
want to show her brother her true
potential and purposely held herself
back so that her brother wouldn't be
able to manipulate and use her to his
own advantages this is why senju has
been given the moniker or nickname of
the unrivalled or unmatched just how
like mikey has been given the nickname
of the invincible
now still sticking with the so-called
warring states period while the tokyo
sengoku period or warring states period
is something that i think the author has
actually taken from the real-life
japanese warring states period within a
certain period of time called the
sengoku period so many damn periods this
was a time throughout japanese history
of near-constant civil war social
upheaval and intrigue from 1467 to 1615.
obviously the real period in history
lasted much longer than in the uh manga
but i think the overall outcome is
extremely similar to what is currently
happening in the story the real life
scene goku period was named by japanese
historians after the similar but
otherwise unrelated warring states
period of china and modern japan
recognizes nobunaga hideyoshi and ayusa
as the three great unifiers for the
restoration of the central government
and their country
again in tokyo avengers we haven't had
the so-called restoration but we have
had a period of time that is called the
warring states period and after this
time came to an end in the manga three
extremely powerful people rose and took
command being given the moniker of the
three deities which is extremely similar
to the so-called three unifiers of japan
these three unifiers of japan have
varying personalities that i think match
to each different deity extremely well
the first of these unifiers oda nobunaga
was a japanese daimo and one of the
leading figures during the sengoku
period he is regarded as the first great
unifier of japan his reputation and war
gave him the nickname of demon dyimo or
demon king honestly those are some real
awesome nicknames and i think he
perfectly matches up against mikey who
has become a bit of a demonic figure
throughout this last arc here the second
of the three is toyotomi hideyoshi
toyotomi rose from a peasant background
as a retainer of the prominent lord oda
nobunaga to become one of the most
powerful men in japan hideyoshi
succeeded nobunaga after the honjoji
incident in 1582 and continued
nobunaga's campaign to unite japan that
led to the closing of this in goku
period i feel like the second unifier
here almost perfectly describes who
senchu is as toyotomi was especially
well known for his resourcefulness and i
think senju has just shown how extremely
resourceful she actually is being able
to gain the allegiance of the first
generation black dragons along with
draken and takamichi and all for the
goal of following in mikey's footsteps
and becoming the number one delinquent
gang in all of japan will at least put
it simply enough that's what she's
trying to do when it comes to south i
found it extremely hard to pin him to a
certain unifier of japan and in all
honesty the last of the three unifiers
more suits takamichi than anybody else
the third unifier of japan was tokugawa
aiesu tokugaka was well known especially
for his perseverance and i think we all
know just how much takamichi has
persevered throughout the entire story
so far which is why i found it extremely
hard to gauge exactly where south would
fall as he kind of takes a little from
each unifier as he is extremely ruthless
and through this ruthlessness he was
able to become resourceful enough and
grow his game by defeating previous vice
captains of other gangs which obviously
shows his determination or at least i
think it does when it comes to brahman i
think there may be some influence from
hindu philosophy as brahman itself the
name of the gang in japanese kanji which
is on the back of the uniform means
purity buddhist and sanskrit sanskrit is
usually just used in religious texts in
asian regions of the world but generally
sanskrit is a compound word consisting
of san meaning good well together or
like perfected and
meaning made formed or work so it is
implying that a work has been well
prepared pure and perfect is polished
and or sacred pretty much in my eyes
it's stating that brahman itself means
perfected or possibly even polished and
pure a more direct translation of
brahman though or like the word itself
comes through hinduism where it implies
that it is the highest universal
principle or the ultimate reality in all
of the universe which honestly sounds
absolutely crazy and actually might give
us some kind of like context to this
mysterious fire that seems to glow off
her while she fights in battle
also in like major hindu philosophy
schools brahman is the material
efficient formal and final cause of all
that exists it is a persuasive infinite
external truth and bliss which does not
change yet is the cause of all changes
brahman as a metaphysical concept refers
to the single binding unity behind
diversity and all that exists in the
universe so again in my eyes this is
kind of stating that brahman is pretty
much the final or the cause of
everything and could be the possible
reason as to why everything is turning
out so badly in each different timeline
brahman is also interestingly enough a
gender-neutral concept that implies
greater impersonality than masculine or
female conceptions of the deity
brahman is referred to as the supreme
self polyganda states it as the
unchanging reality amidst and beyond the
world while sinha states brahman is a
concept that cannot be exactly defined
which is something that has almost been
an underlying concept throughout the
entire story so far if you think about
it the fact that no matter what nothing
can be exactly denied takamichi may
change the past in some way or another
but possibly always at the cost of
someone else's misfortune so pretty much
equal exchange but if you'd like to hear
more about like brahman and take a more
in-depth look into the possible relation
between senju and how she could more or
less relate to senju kenon the thousand
armed goddess of mercy then be sure to
let me know down in the comment section
below videos like these take a bunch of
effort having to read up on certain
ideologies and religions and we all know
that from past stories authors often
like to base their works off or around
things like folk tales and ancient
historic stories so there is always a
possibility that something like this
could actually definitely be the case
but if you have enjoyed the video and
want to see more stuff just like this in
the future be sure to hit that subscribe
button and if you want to support me uh
one step further than that then be sure
to check out my youtube membership
option for as little as only like a
dollar u.s a month as i'm thinking about
making a private discord for members who
do join that as well only if you're
interested though so be sure to let me
know down in the comment section below
and i'll get on to that right away if
you guys are anyways i hope you all have
a lovely day morning night or even sleep
but for now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in april bye
[Music]